[Música]
el gobierno de reino unido va a proponer
este lunes desmantelar partes el llamado
protocolo de irlanda el norte del norte
uno de los puntos de fricción acordados
con la unión europea para sellar el
proxy del pacto que entró en vigor en
año 2021 que busca evitar el retorno de
una frontera física entre irlanda y
también irlanda del norte haciendo que
esta última se mantenga bajo las reglas
aduaneras del bloque comunitario el
secretario y la nica de exteriores
disfrazo aseguró que bruselas debe estar
dispuesta a cambiar las reglas que rigen
en comercio con irlanda del norte a
través de una solución negociada
el primer ministro boris johnson por su
parte aseguró que una retaliación
comercial por parte de la unión europea
sería una reacción exagerada vamos a
entonces analizar este tema con nuestro
segundo invitado del día el s oscar
guardiola escritor y profesor de break
college university of london gracias al
profesor oscar por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 preguntó
entonces por qué sigue siendo este tema
un balón a rueda por así decirlo en las
relaciones con la unión europea
y obviamente entre el reino unido y la
unión europea
el tema sigue siendo controversial
porque se trataría en efecto de una
denuncia unilateral de un acuerdo
negociado entre dos partes lo que por
supuesto de manera muy evidente
rompería el
derecho internacional y de otra parte
porque tal como están las cosas la
situación
en irlanda del norte se hace cada vez
más difícil las consecuencias que ha
tenido break set para el comercio no
solo entre los dos países irlanda del
norte como parte del reino unido y la
república de irlanda que comparten e
irlanda del norte y la república una
misma masa territorial como lolo lo que
basta de decir sino que además está
teniendo un efecto
muy desigual entre diversas partes del
reino unido lo que es claro es que
existe
o apetito y muy poca confianza
respecto de que el gobierno de volition
sólo pueda en efecto resolver el
problema sin hacerle daño al acuerdo de
viernes santo y sin romper el derecho
internacional ahora profesor por qué
ocurre esto precisamente cuáles son los
puntos que digamos son molestan a reino
unido en este acuerdo post praxis
digamos que hay dos dimensiones
en lo que hace a la molestia entre
comillas el gobierno británico una
dimensión es económica y tiene que ver
con el hecho de que al negociarse con la
unión europea el levantamiento de la
mayor parte de los obstáculos
aduaneros
para la circulación de bienes y
servicios entre irlanda del norte y la
república de irlanda se ha producido un
efecto
diferente
mientras que irlanda del norte tiene una
economía más fuerte el resto de las
naciones del reino unido- vende caer su
economía con mucha rapidez
y esto por supuesto aquí viene la
segunda dimensión afecta políticamente
al gobierno conservador que fue elegido
bajo la promesa de que existirá diría
ventajas económicas a todo el reino
unido no está siendo el caso y de hecho
lo que estamos viendo es que él
mayor unión que de facto existe en la
frontera entre irlanda del norte y la
república de blanda hace que es su
economía se vea menos afectada de manera
de es más desfavorable que las otras las
de las otras naciones del reino unido
así que hay un doble golpe para el
gobierno de johnson de una parte el
económico y de otra parte el político
también porque sus antiguos aliados en
el lado del norte han perdido cada vez
más apoyo político y por supuesto culpan
de ello al gobierno de westminster y
digamos también como dicen sus
contradictores para restarle un poco de
importancia y johnson dice que se trata
de cambios insignificantes a lo pactado
cuando hicieron toda esta negociación
del próximo del documento de la salida
de reino unido de la unión europea estos
estos cambios realmente son
insignificantes y además se quiere
preguntarse y supondrían en un
rompimiento con la ley internacional en
que estaría incumpliendo el reino unido
y yo se lo aseguró esta mañana en medios
que en efecto se tratarían de cambios
más bien triviales fue la frase que
utilizó a cine por supuesto entrar en
detalles enseguida la reacción tanto
desde irlanda del norte como desde la
república de blanda y también dentro de
el reino unido ha sido de desconfianza
al respecto de esas afirmaciones
porque porque no se trata de una serie
de cambios triviales por supuesto los
cambios tienen que ver con reglas
aduanera y de comercio que aplica la
unión europea no solamente a la frontera
entre irlanda del norte y la república
de irlanda es decir una frontera la
unión europea sino a todas las fronteras
de la unión europea difícilmente podría
haber una europea cambiar las reglas
solamente para una parte de sus
fronteras eso hay una parte de la otra
el acuerdo ya había sido negociado
y por eso la unión europea no aparece
interesada en volver a negociar lo que
ya había sido negociado es más bien el
gobierno de johnson el que al intentar
ocultar el hecho de que brasil está
teniendo un efecto
muy desfavorable para el resto de la
economía británica está intentando hacer
una serie de cambios que por ser
unilaterales no son aceptables en
derecho internacional y ese es el punto
no puede ser trivial decir que yo solo
de manera unilateral claro en cambio los
términos de una negociación sin
preguntarle a mi contraparte y sin
consultar a todas las partes que van a
ser afectados por esos cambios ahora
profesor también hay quiero preguntar si
en el momento pues de hacer efectivo el
project sit ya boris johnson se podría
imaginar una situación en la que estamos
ahora digamos que hay como éste yo tengo
mi posición firme por parte del reino
unido- urias también dice yo también
tengo mi posición firme y no la voy a
cambiar pero cuál sería la reacción de
bruselas ante lo que pretende hoy el
gobierno de reino unido y también le voy
a preguntar también por qué se baraja
sobre la mesa la posibilidad de una
guerra comercial esto la podemos ver si
no se ponen de acuerdo digamos
y la respuesta a la primera pregunta es
que todo esto era anticipable de hecho
las advertencias se habían hecho desde
el comienzo y por eso siempre fue
difícil llegar a intentar resolver
lo que se veía venir y es que por
supuesto en el momento en que se
produjese el exit iba a existir por
reactivarse algún tipo de control
fronterizo entre irlanda del norte y la
república de irlanda y eso era evidente
y todos los intentos por resolverlo han
sido banales o inanes y en todo caso el
poco efectivos en segundo lugar la
reacción del órgano europea ha sido
simplemente apuntar que mal podría como
lo dije antes la unión de aplicar las
normas aduaneras
se acordaron con el gobierno británico
no puede la unión europea aceptar un
cambio unilateral a una a una tratado
negociado y por ello y en tercer lugar
ha advertido la posibilidad de que se
tomen una serie de medidas que
afectarían por supuesto el comercio
hablar de guerra aduanera quizás se
suene muy fuerte y habrá que esperar
cuál sea la reacción pero el riesgo es
claro y existe